what's up
bud here to talk to
Zachary unless you want to look at
obstruction don't do that we're not here
for you we're here to talk to
him all right all right what you doing
we're working what's he doing right now
B what' he tell you to do what what he
tell you to do told us he told
me
okay he's got a warrant that's why he's
playing that I you're good you're good
I'm saying he did but at this point
like if he's trying to get you involved
in it it's not worth you
charge that's fine we're see if talk Z
we know that's
Zach all
right
go
your
call
check
than
C shut it off shut it
off
you're going to get tag
Jack the
street
J back up toward
now
a
shut it off now shut it
off all right get back you're going to
get hurt
stop stop it
now hold
one on that war part of the county about
a minute
away T's continuing heast through a
field he shot him was Good
Steer
motherfucker just turn this into a
f
do any units coming have them head up to
Old St 55 area it's a white Skit Steer
orange L in the
back
yo
w
41 he in a three just off in5 he's not
in the
anymore or when you're clear
free no longer in that vehicle
the
fuck God damn
it
what he looks like it's a white long
beard white male is that Henry yeah
hey we got felony chars on
them I lost them we just found Skit
[Music]
Steer
guys Lu with somebody yeah I got to
running on foot around here you long
beard white
male all right 321 okay yeah he just hit
me with the skid steer so all right long
white yeah long beard do what how old
say like 35 all right all
thanks
A9 working
now
[Music]
Che one and
hey what's your hair that's me oh that's
you are
you're all
right sent you a proper
rep two any County units I me if someone
could swing back to the original
property he could have double back
there me out 11 West
North
[Music]
please
f
what's the he what uh Brown sweatshirt
long BL or brownish
beard
which way did you see him last he was
coming through this field after hitting
me with the skid steer so he might have
went back but it looks like there's
Footprints
here
be out at 4
probably
got track yeah so what I'm
falling I think
so
is there any start down
there
no he didn't come this way
motherfucker
there got jum
everybody dud just information and he's
got a 15 and then felony charges from
this
4 21 car two
down sear huh y can search
me is that your
Bobcat is that your dad or anything I
work with
okay
is any of these vehicles his that he
drove here
today how's he drive huh how's he drive
what does he normally Drive D that this
I just made contact
with
I chance do you know like you know the
second cop that pulled up yeah right
when y'all pulled up uh do you know his
badge
number like what his name is and all
that could have been 31 31 I don't know
cuz he I'm a 13-year-old kid and he over
here was like trying to get information
on me I said I don't know nothing and he
was like he's like no tell me what's
going on and I was like all right and
then he was like I was like PA comes
out he about ran him over with the skid
steer and we know that that's going to
kill him yeah but then after that he
said you don't look like you're 13 to be
fair I'm 13 I got got to be here my your
mom's coming here yeah
[Music]
okay well I don't know when she's coming
here but she's supposed to be on her way
back
okay
[Applause]
show me out to 1300 chest
Drive
[Music]
up I'm going to
[Applause]
have
[Music]
Pi 230 go
ahead going to be the Caitlyn
Murphy
[Applause]
44 here the smelling of
Kaitlyn
[Music]
[Applause]
23 did you have this selling for
but
[Music]
yeah
put 230 are
you G22 on
[Music]
me
[Applause]
disgard
location
20's
[Music]
[Applause]
Qui
for
[Applause]
kid said this is what he's been normally
driving
who owns
this he said it's not
his he said he's just working for this
guy this guy the guy
ran says mom's coming to
get you're working for Zach yeah who
does he work for
no okay that's does he live here I don't
know you're not in any trouble we're
just trying to figure out I don't know
nothing about no I know I
got older than what I am yeah sure he's
13 you're 13 that's what I
said so you just meet Zach here yeah
skid steer's his the one he ran in this
is that Bobcat I think
so well it's coun now
yeah good luck getting it
out yeah we'll cross that
bridge
14 and
I all
right
well you think the family want to Skid
Steer to run H me
with
me on the
fucking